Jackson do you like bento lunches you're
about to find out Pinterest moms what
are they and why am I talking about them
today well let me tell you a Pinterest
mom is a rare breed of mother who is
just like the most extra so she's that
mom who makes the homemade birthday
party favors at every party she's that
mom who home cooks every meal she's the
mom who's cleaning products in her home
are all made from scratch this is like
the complete opposite of everything I'm
used to and the way I am as a parent but
I want to give it a shot I want to try
something new so for one week I'm going
to be a Pinterest mom I'm not gonna be
able to quit my job or like stop all my
other responsibilities but in all my
free time I'm going to act as if I was a
Pinterest mom and see how it goes okay
so I'm trolling Pinterest and today is
Sunday so I'm gonna take full advantage
of that and the fact that I don't go to
work and do three activities I'm gonna
find a food a DIY for my kids to play
with and a DIY to better my household
back then hi thank this lunch took me
about half an hour to make I tried to do
the puzzle piece sandwich which doesn't
really work so having kids of two
different ages five and two a lot of
these Pinterest things that I spent a
lot of time on were completely lost on
Wyatt he's like two years old he doesn't
care who thirty minutes on this lunch
and this is what's left but Jackson was
another story oh you saw their puzzle
pieces yeah oh my gosh worth it yeah it
was nice to see that he was interacting
with a lot of the stuff that I was
making his sweet no now I'm going to
make these popsicles I saw that looks
super easy on Pinterest it says you just
mix sprite and gummy bears and a
popsicle mold and it makes these really
cute clear popsicles with gummy bear
[Music]
okay I'm on my third task and it is DIY
garbage disposal pots because apparently
you made these to keep your garbage
disposal smelling fresh they seem fairly
easy I actually found them from nifty on
Facebook and so if nifty you can do it I
can do it
why don't you understand how people find
the hours of the day to do all of this
so this is my garbage disposal pod
mixture like cut it sticky and then I'm
just gonna pack it into this silicone
ice cube old and I guess it takes 24
hours for these to like dry so I can't
use them till tomorrow the final
Pinterest craft for today is making your
own fun shaped crayon I don't understand
this one but basically you buy a pack of
crayons like regular crayons and then
break them up and combine the colors and
put them in a silicone baking mold do
not forget to take the paper off
speaking of my kids anytime I did one of
these projects I'd turn around and
there'd be a giant frickin mask behind
me because my back was turning for so
long and I was distracted for so long my
kids would take every opportunity to
like do whatever they wanted hey these
are done they look very questionable I
do not understand these like just give
your kid a pack of crayons we just spent
six dollars on this silicone mold in 45
minutes
making these okay we're on day three and
I tried using one of these garbage
disposal pods and they are completely
crumbling and they don't work so I did
something wrong and also I need to go to
work so
failing and making their Penta lunches
because it's either make that or get
dressed for work and I need to show up
for work and clothes I think that's
important so fail today so why didn't I
just get up a little bit earlier to get
all this stuff done Wow I already get up
very early to go to work and I work
pretty far away from where I live so my
commute is three hours total but it
wasn't all bad I'll say this you know if
I didn't work full time I can totally
understand how that can be really
exciting to do and really fun to do and
you can take the time to incorporate
your kids into a lot of these crafts and
a lot of these projects so I totally
forgot about these popsicles I've made
with the gummi bears and sprite and
first they completely exploded all over
the freezer I don't know if you can tell
but they're dripped all over oh man it
all got in the bottom oh that doesn't
look anything like the picture that's
kind of a fail oh that's good those
popsicles were a giant fail and then I
realized after turns out that's a
picture of soap it's not even a freaking
popsicle it's soap it's a bar of soap
that's why it's so clear because it's
glycerin so per usual it's day four day
four and I'm super super late for work I
don't have time to make bento lunches
but I bought a nutribullet and I'm gonna
make my kids of green smoothie this
morning so I hope that counts by like
the fourth day I really got the hang of
the nutribullet and that was really
really helpful that was the one like
useful thing that came out of this week
think of this I found that because it
really was coming down to like do I put
on a shirt or do I slice this bread like
a key I need to decide right now okay
day six I got it together I mean
lunches I'm super super super late for
work and I have a 9:30 a.m. meeting so I
hope I'm not late for that
and that's all I got today so far okay
so it is the final day oh my god thank
goodness so tonight I'm gonna make
pandas shaped macaroons they seem to be
like the most complicated thing I've
found on Pinterest figured I'd end with
a bang this has been quite a journey and
then I just realized I don't know where
my electric beaters are so this is gonna
be really fun trying to whisk eggs by
hand I beat those things with a whisk
for 45 minutes but they worked
I like pipe down out of a ziplock bag
I like decorated I'm out of his if lock
bag I like smacked the pan on the floor
to like try to get off the air bubbles
which is something I guess they're
supposed to do it was like completely
like macgyvered everything was totally
not the way it's supposed to I haven't
actually fed them to my kids yet I just
like ate them in the middle of the night
and that was that it was so worth it
treat yourself right so in conclusion I
learned a lot this week and I gained a
lot of respect for Pinterest mom's and
pumps in general before when I would see
Pinterest crafts or like think about the
moms who did that sort of stuff I just
kind of do a giant eye roll and like
disregarded as something stupid but I
learned this week that it really is
worth it it's fulfilling and it's fun
and I really wish I could be more like
that so definitely an overall learning
experience not something I'm going to be
doing ever again in the near future but
it was fun for that week and tune in to
see what I do next
till next time
does it make you want to eat it
it's about cheese
[Music]